new show animals doing okay now I
understand it that you're a seventh also
because your wife's a big animal lover
right well the crazy animal lover okay
so I doing this show based on an
Instagram page called animals doing
things in NatGeo and I voice it and
everything and I did it because I was
trying to get on my way
my wife is angry with me because I get
on her she rescues she says she rescue
she doesn't rescue my wife takes my wife
doesn't know if it passes her path if
anything she picks it up and brings look
what I rescued it's it's got a shiny
coat it's got tags it's you you know it
was rescuing it the guy ringing the
doorbell now that wants his puppy back
yeah that's who rescued it so let me
just tell you something so she rescued a
couple weeks ago she goes she picked up
a cat a stray cat and the cat bit her
this is a true story I'm gonna wrap it
up in one second okay the third cat the
cat bit her blood everywhere blood
everywhere
she have to take her to the - what'd he
call it the doc veterinarian no my wife
is bleeding not the cat so they give her
two stitches but now that's Kaddu
stitches for anybody listen to me I got
to wrap it up okay so so now she has to
go get a shot in her stomach every week
because she could have rabies do you
know what that means yes didn't know but
what that means look at me I'm the
biggest germaphobe in the world I won't
shake hands I won't touch I sleep with a
woman that might have rabies
[Applause]
animals doing things Saturday on Nat Geo
I think we have a clip here from animals
doing things that doesn't matter we have
to wrap it up they have time for a clip
no no so no we're not showing the clip
don't try to decide who this guy's not
in charge while the evening charm
we're not showing the clip no clip the
show no spoilers
talent airs Tuesdays at 8:00 on NBC and
animals doing things air Saturdays at
10:00 not geo wild time and over her
back
you